what do you what do you guys think about
people that are religious that you know
they've been raised and their religion
obviously goes back for a very long time
and a lot of people still I'm so I'm
Muslim I don't think I could ever be
comfortable with accepting new terms for
oh like I just I just don't think I
never do it but I don't think I'd you
know I think it's fine if you don't want
to accept things but also you're not
really gonna be able to engage in
arguments if you're not the point of
arguments and debate is you're trying to
meet someone in the middle so that you
can have a conducive you can't you can't
engage in an argument unless you engage
it in the way that I think is right is
basically right now you need to be
not unless she's forced to use language
that she's not comfortable using